Hello I'm a citizen.
And I'm the government, and we are building a brand new sports ball stadium.
I love sports ball.
Great because we are building it right where your house used to be.
What?
I don't want to sell my house.
Oh oh I'm not asking.
Wait did—did you use the past tense?
Hello I'm a citizen.
And I'm the government.
My friends and I have been concerned about you using excessive force.
Ahhh!
Hello I'm a citizen.
And I'm the government.
We've decided to push our transportation infrastructure by building a brand new streetcar.
Okay that could help me get from home to work.
Oh great you live between third and fifth street?
No I live on 24th street.
Oh.
Is it going to go to 24th street?
Nope.